let's just ask him anyways babe i feel
like the world wants to get to know
george kimmel a little better oh can i
say something really quick
no no it's a good thing it's just funny
that so uh me and george met in pasadena
and then we met up with cindy for lunch
after our meeting over there and then
after we were done eating cindy goes
is it just me or is he like really white
i lost my god she loves you it's just
that i never thought she would say
anything like that because she's so like
is it just because my voice sounds like
every black comedian's impression of a
white guy i think so oh oh write that
down yeah write that down
oh you were testing it i always tested
it two times ago and then it didn't get
any laughs you just gotta write that
down yeah really great great response
hey george where have you been writing
this down and why you've been writing
stuff shut up gilbert stop trying to set
me up what have you been doing on the
weekends i've been writing some stamina
hold on george so are we um do you have
a girlfriend
oh no are you dating a lot
when was the last time you got your dick
wet
goddammit uh
they've asked them questions yeah i
don't give a [ __ ]
i want to know come on george let me
know all right let me explain yes
recently you have to be specific you're
on the hot seat here
uh saturday but it's been a while before
that was it somebody um what's her name
what's her full name her age uh it was a
bumble girl oh just random do you still
love jessica just imagine do you still
love jessica everyone in the room
imagine
george's penis erect
no just listen
right
and he's got a girl in the bed she gets
naked i love it right and he's slowly
you know creeped i don't know how he
does it his approach maybe kisses the
thighs to get to the back
i know that's what i'm saying all right
but look at his face and then sticking
and then sticking his ugly ass pink
penis
on the
edge of a woman's entrance and sliding
it in yep and then him going oh
like making that noise right and he
pumps and she she
has to pretend she likes it so she has
to go
feels good or whatever
right and then him going i'm gonna come
it means oh
oh that thought of him coming and then
imagine his face
his face turns all red
right
the veins
under his eyelids pop out right why are
they popping and
its face is vibrating right it goes oh
like that old korean oh my god your face
doesn't look that much better either
can i show you guys what bobby's face
looks like what
do you want to do or no yeah
really yeah do it it's
a japanese noodle commercial
always it's like when i this is the
worst podcast we've ever done
i also i also think we should just get
to the questions and maybe do a couple
yeah we have two actually okay good go
ahead unhelpful advice with all right
and george [ __ ] think about his erect
penis second city right there uh